this afternoon Chinese understands of
the GP surgery in Brighton has been
closed after being linked to one of the
four new coronavirus cases those cases
that have been reported today it is the
County Oak Medical Center in Brighton so
that's just a development coming in
artists and again it's all about when
somebody contracts this virus tracing
their steps tracing their movements yes
it's thought that what well it's it's
been confirmed that one of the people
one of the four people who have been
identified today went to or either went
to it will work in that GP surgery you
know we haven't got the full
confirmation but certainly we understand
that is true that GP surgery is closed
in connection with one of the four
people who are identified today whether
they were a patient or whether they're a
member of staff aware that we don't know
we will find that out but certainly
Department of Health public health
England NHS England all working very
quickly to try and trace contact I find
out exactly who this person was in
contact with don't forget there are two
flights at least two flights involved
here there's a major long-haul flight
and international flight from Singapore
to Britain this you know if this British
president was carrying it then he could
have passed it on to other passengers
and then there's a short haul flight
from Europe back to Britain so there are
two plane carriers involved there as
well and this just gives you an
indication ok the mortality rate is low
thankfully it's very low at two percent
but just the spread the rate of
infection is very high
you